well i have to ask about another big
movie that you've got coming this fall
because i'm a nerd about marvel and
marvel's the eternals um you're in that
so how cool is that
that's like uh shocking it's it's beyond
cool i think it's a miracle
and i love it that i'm in the one marvel
movie that it's completely diverse
and it's very different than all the
other ones i'm gonna love it
i am such a freak fan for all of it
um and i don't think it's crazy i'm not
behind the scenes in
the actor world or whatever so i don't
know like as far as casting but i think
it's so normal to see you
and something like that so um but you
say it kelly can i ask you a question
i'm sorry yeah i know i'm not supposed
to
interview interviewing you but how cool
it is
that our director for that movie
it's the second woman
that actually wins an oscar for best
director
that's amazing that's amazing
wow super proud i that no that's amazing
that's incredible
annotation exactly and it's like such
such great progress like i think
sometimes we get you know kind of bummed
out a bit as females too like in
as far as equal pay and other things
like in the entertainment industry and
it's really cool when we like focus on
that
the positive things like that that's
really cool i cannot wait to see it i'm
very excited no joke
everyone here will tell you i'm a nerd
about marvel stuff so
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever